from massive AAA experiences like
Horizon forbidden West to smaller indie
games like sons of the forest open world
games are a huge part of what we play
despite this many developers and
Publishers rarely reuse old areas and
old maps from previous entries part of
me gets why a developer wouldn't want to
do this I mean just look at the response
the Spider-Man 2 gameplay reveal got but
I also think revisiting worlds can lead
to some interesting storytelling
opportunities in fact I'd even go as far
to say that familiar open worlds can
make some games even better
when I heard twos of the Kingdom would
take place in the same high rulers
breath of the wild I was disappointed
and a little skeptical the follow-up to
one of Nintendo's most revolutionary
titles was reusing the map that I and
many others had already spent hundreds
of hours exploring little did I know the
familiar map may be one of Tears of the
Kingdom's greatest strengths now
developers reuse assets all the time
this isn't new and it's not going away
anytime soon Ragnarok uses many of the
same animations from God of War 2018.
Call of Duty will dust off and
re-implement reload animations for
returning guns even Nintendo yanked
entire character animations and 3D
objects from Ocarina of Time and drop
them into Majora's Mask typically this
is done to save time money and resources
however it's pretty rare for a game to
reuse an entire map even when a game has
you revisit a location from a past entry
that space has been reinterpreted
significantly altered or it only plays a
small role in the overall package the
Mass Effect series has you return to the
Citadel multiple times throughout the
trilogy but each time you visit a
different District Metal Gear Solid 4
sees snake returning to Shadow Moses but
it has been changed by the passage of
time and Red Dead Redemption 2 lets you
explore some areas from the original but
it feels pretty underutilized nearly
every Zelda game takes place in Hyrule
but each entry features a very different
interpretation of that world for me a
new world to explore has always been an
important part of any sequel well that
is until I played tears of the kingdom
when I left the sky islands in first
touchdown on Central Hyrule I felt like
I was returning home after a long trip
the calm field stretched into the
distance Hyrule Castle loomed over the
emerald green plains Death Mountain
jutted up from the Horizon bringing with
it memories of me clamoring the Behemoth
years ago I get it there's something
exciting about exploring a brand new
world but it can be equally comforting
to revisit an old one sure Nostalgia can
be intoxicating especially when it comes
to a series like Zelda but I also think
revisiting an old map can often lead to
some interesting opportunities from a
design and mechanical standpoint one of
the most obvious examples is the
player's relationship with the mini-map
the way I see it mini maps are kind of
the necessary evil it can take a very
long time for players to familiarize
themselves with a map as sprawling as
Hyrule minimaps prevent the player from
constantly checking the map every few
minutes tears of the Kingdom has a
minimap but I never use it why because I
know my way around Hyrule now I don't
want to downplay Nintendo's fantastic
World design here as you explore your
eyes are naturally drawn to important
locations and the colorful biomes make
each area feel distinct but I also just
knew where I was going help the readout
okay that's in the Northwest tucked away
in the Hebrew mountains help the grudo
alright let's head Southwest and prepare
for the heat part of feeling at home in
a town city or neighborhood in the real
world is knowing exactly how to get from
one place to another without having to
think too hard about it I know how to
get to my favorite restaurants coffee
shops and Parks without a hitch and
there's a Warmness to that familiarity
that makes you feel even more connected
to the areas around around you I feel
the same when I explore Hyrule there is
something we're missing though one of
the most compelling aspects of Tears of
the Kingdom's map is how it's changed
over the years new settlements have
popped up characters have gotten older
the infrastructure has evolved and of
course the upheaval has littered the
land with debris the world has moved on
from the events of breath of the wild
but you can still see the ghosts of
hyrule's past ghosts not only from an
ancient civilization but that goes from
Link's previous Adventure that we got to
participate in the Zelda series is
steeped in forlorn legends about heroes
from the past and ancient villains but
for the first time in the series you get
to return to the same place that you
saved a few years ago you are already
part of that Legend and you can see the
direct outcome of the legend that you
lived you're an active participant in
hyrule's history and that's a uniquely
powerful experience that is rarely
realized one other series that does let
you be an active participant in history
and witness a world as it evolves over
30 years is none other than Yakuza
[Music]
foreign
games are special for many reasons but
one of the most fascinating aspects of
the entire series is how multi-layered
the fictional District of kamarocho is
settings especially in games are often
compared to characters it makes sense
given how video games more than any
other medium let you explore a fictional
space at your own Leisure but most of
these settings are typically missing one
thing the passage of time rarely do we
get to see these spaces change and
evolve in meaningful ways GTA 5 feels
like an early 2010s Time Capsule at this
point one that was informed by the pop
culture of the era now don't get me
wrong art is supposed to reflect the
culture of its time but it also makes
these beautifully detailed worlds feel
as though they're stuck in a vacuum
nothing gets in and characters never
grow old meanwhile kamarocho feels like
a real place that changes with the times
it has kept the same layout same streets
and even some of the same buildings and
businesses that date back to the first
Yakuza from 2005 but each iteration
Paints the streets of kamarocho with a
slightly different stroke to reflect the
Changing Times new technologies
introduced characters move in and out
and businesses open and close it's a
form of long-term storytelling and World
building that games rarely get to
explore because they never stick to one
location between games and it's a shame
because that can lead to some
deep-seated player attachment for
example in the Yakuza games restaurants
play a major role because they're how
you recover health you're incentivized
to visit these places to take a tiny
break relax and admire the gorgeous
pictures of food and beer it's easy to
form an attachment to these places over
time just like how we do with food
haunts in real life that coffee shop you
stop at in the morning on the way to
work started as a simple way to get that
good good Bean drip that you need to be
a functioning person but over time it's
familiar Comfort brings its own value
one of my favorite examples of this
comes from my pal Jean Luke and his
experience with a takayaki stand and
Yakuza 0 through two it's at the
intersection of Tenkaichi Street and
taihe Boulevard he'd stop there to take
a quick breather and enjoy the moment
before slamming some dude's face into
the pavement now katayaku is a three
that wonderful takayaki spot had been
replaced with a gelato shop it seems
gentrification even comes for camarocho
returning to kamarocho every few years
is not unlike returning to your hometown
and finding comfort in what remained the
same all these years and being a
heartbroken when something from your
childhood is no longer around look I'm
not here to Advocate that every game
should reuse old maps in fact I think
that would be a pretty bad decision one
of my favorite things about games is
exploring these new and Fantastical
worlds but I do think that in some cases
a familiar open world can make for a
stronger experience and stir emotions
that other settings just can't and tears
of the kingdom is a fantastic example of
that
foreign
[Music]